people used to take my raps and crunch
them up and throw them on the ground I
used to get made fun of all the times
who believes that the guy sitting next
to my math class is going to blow up
become a superstar you don't like that
right the like you should don't listen
to what the cool people say man they're
not cool do what do you do well use cool
just contribute you wake up and look a
bomb you're not contributing you're just
being lazy just getting by man he's an
American rapper and actor from Cleveland
Ohio his major label debut album lace up
was released in 2012 to critical acclaim
his second studio album general
admission debuted at number four in the
u.s. is Machine Gun Kelly and here's my
take on his top ten rules of success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best also guys as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down in the comments below and put
quotes around it to other people can be
inspired also when you write it down
it's much more likely to lock in for
yourself as well
enjoy
what you represent now for all those
kids out there trying to make it
whatever field it is whether it's music
or something else what words do you have
for them in terms of how you live your
life and you've made it to this point
because you're not supposed to supposed
to be here right now now what advice you
have for them in terms of their lives in
their journey lace up what it's like
what is lace-up mean for say it you know
it's the casual person that might be
seeing you for the first time on the
show
what is lace-up I mean I mean it means
what you want it to be but to me in a
day and age like this it means put both
feet on the ground lace up you're ready
to face the world go out there take it
on and and you know turn a grain of sand
into a diamond you know I'm saying yeah
I think they love that answer right
there
they're definitely laced and that's what
it's about man you know what it's about
it's about believing in something you
know what I'm saying like having faith
in something man like that's what it is
like we're not trying to hear some we're
not trying to hear some you know
president in the suit who you know came
and lived his own life and you know like
because he's so worried about public for
said we can't relate to that you know
I'm saying like they want to see someone
doing what they're doing living how
they're living coming from where they're
coming from and like making something
better themselves and just sitting on
the rest you know I'm saying like that's
why that's why they're screaming they
like take because they they see that
emotion I'm at
when I'm coming like on the side one
that's going to be the People's Champ
yeah no I mean like I don't I don't want
to hear some Reverend tell me I have to
believe in organized religion I don't
want to hear some president something
we're going to do we're not going to do
because they never do it I don't want to
hear some teacher put a limit on where
my education could take me you know I'm
saying like they want to teach me to you
know go and fix lights in the house but
you don't want to tell me that I can
take my own career into my own hands and
be an entrepreneur and come up with
something like this they didn't teach
you you could do this yeah I'm just I'm
just not I'm not scared man I'm ready to
step up and be a leader for this
generation would be a voice for the
generation and all these people can act
like they're talking for these kids but
it's just an act like I'm still one of
those kids math like this means the
world to me and that's that's what this
album is about I just know I just know
things are going to change man it's I
feel it I feel it I believe in like
people used to take my raps and crunch
them up and throw them on the ground I
used to get made fun of all the time is
who believes that the guy sitting next
in a math class is going to blow up
become a superstar you don't like that
right but like you should and it's a
bummer you know I mean because I yeah I
don't know man I mean take it take it
make you know pain is the best
inspiration so if you're creative out
there you're getting bully take it make
something great out of it yeah don't let
cool people tell you you're not cool mmm
they're not cool mm-hmm so you know I
was a loser for you know bye-bye
stereotype for many years and it's like
the classic case of look at me now you
know what I mean so I mean let me tell
you something if you're out there right
now and you like have no idea who you
are or what you belong to it took me I
mean it took me I just figured out last
year last year was the first time I ever
looked in the mirror and was like I like
that guy it took me 25 years so and you
know I don't know don't listen I don't
listen to what the cool people say man
they're not cool do what do you do what
you do is cool when you came up with the
Waka Flocka record to this there's like
a big difference in your style
your approach what's the reason for that
probably because we grow and evolution
is beautiful and like I want to be
iconic and great and I borderline am
iconic and I am great so like it's like
there's only thing left to do is clear
it is to just evolve and continue to do
so I mean like I'm responsible for like
possibly bringing rock'n'roll just in
general into hip-hop within our
generation and like making that whole
wave a cool thing and influencing all
those artists when we were doing those
festivals back together in the 2012 and
2011 2010 years when wild blue was
nothing and when so many other mixtapes
on that I was doing weird things so like
yes when like I brought what I brought
in and everyone else took it like I do
what all trendsetters do and I like just
set a new trend and do on to the next
thing and let them keep doing you know
that I had that run on lace-up where I
had invincible which was the rest of you
so right for 28,000 people messed that
whole thing up could have could have
that could have taken that song to so
much farther than I was but I was so
scared of popularity so scared of like
that that I just ruined it everyone over
I went to radio stations no specific
like yeah I hate this one so uh you know
I bet you guys have fun in there like
well yeah I don't want to play this now
that sucks like that it's like so like I
was like you know what
don't don't don't like prove that you
can you know what I mean like prove that
you can like the most punk rock thing
ever is to get in the system and then do
something about it right so like I
wanted to prove myself that I could be
that person or that or that superstar
essentially right like I've been playing
the cotillion which is where I'm playing
tonight I think it's placed six times in
four years I think your lines we don't
have many times it's been six times so
like where where is the fire going to
come from if you played it six times
right so like okay you're like okay it
is just where I just cap it off and it
just only place it up like as far as I'm
going to get and then I got a call like
hey Meghan Trainor's voice blew out
would you like to replace her on the I
heart jingle balls arena tour for a
couple days and I was like oh
my god yes you're going to let Machine
Gun Kelly come to play jingle balls yes
I am they're full band guitar in hand
let's go and went there tore it up and
that was a fire that I'm like okay now I
want that like now I have something to
redesign for when you go play with Punk
dive bars at first when you're coming on
the scene you're like oh my god is so
going to play it as loud music as ants
but I played it for six years now
namitha crime in so many times if so any
place you're like okay I like I could go
to continue they literally know the
Wi-Fi password or the door to hell I've
done that across the country like oh my
god I noticed overpass for you know
notice Michael why do I notice so much I
go go I open my phone are you recognize
the Wi-Fi from right here so now I have
a new fire and I'm changing that and I
just want to try to keep like topping
myself so bad things I'm very proud
because my fan base and even my
mentality was always like oh man a
street and it's like shut up like you
would be a sellout if you cut yourself
short
you know if you sold yourself short then
like don't and you know obviously the
town was there because bad things hang
out knows me and my writing and it is
now number 10 on the Billboard charts
and number one most added or I could a
top 40 I believe or something like that
and I'm here right now if you're doing
this interview in the top 40 station
think that's really cool then kind of
like not I feel like I'm not selling
myself short now I'm like accomplishing
what they thought I couldn't do what I
thought I couldn't do so I'm not into
people that aren't creative and write
over it you know what I'm saying so like
I like I'm going yeah man I'm like your
dish whatever man like we've been doing
the same for years I want still keep
doing this fatty or so I'm just like
really answer just like like
visionaries and all aspects of it and I
think that like clothes ended up being
something that I just viewed as close
for a while and then there's a dinner
was a mom well the Cloney like it
expresses so much like the fact like he
had the est shirt all right ESC is our
that's our guy that's like our like you
know if it's really true yes it turned
that but it's something that like it's
it's mean something screens off of your
thing like you wear it and they feel
like you have like a you know like a
cape on you don't I mean like and so
I started realizing that clothes are
more than that and you could express so
many things through it and also you
could like when you walk through an
airport and you look foolish that's like
giving people a free movie yeah yeah
that's walking art [ __ ] art is
getting art so like yes like I don't
want to hear no one from my Lu or people
that aren't familiar PS yeah actually
commenting on me you know what would
happen man you circles cuz I don't go
back to the same side whatever but
you're the end of the day I'm living it
but giving you a life to live too cuz
I'm when I'm walking by you you are
feeling any motion just the same way
when I see like people walking by young
old whatever and like that put effort
into like expressing something whether
you look ridiculous or you look like
normal with some Flair whatever I like
that
contributing just contribute you wake up
in with a bomb you're not contributing
you're just being lazy and just getting
by man and like you're not help like I
just look at us look at us on a state of
like of what'swhat's spoon fear yes man
yes totally
but don't you have to create a
Renaissance going on right now though
there's a criminal law right now which
is really cool and so like you know also
like everyone he said that it's a whole
new era like open your creative mind
drop the fear what people say about you
lasts for a day and I go and that's the
thing unless it I'm out for all of 24
hours before they love me the next day
when I put a good song out you know what
I mean it's like I don't care do you be
fearless island dream like
there's so much there's so many so many
doubters dude like I mean you just have
to go to that you have to be a lot
stronger than the people that talk down
on you not i mean like it's a super hard
growing up what it's like not one the
ones who wants to you succeed especially
when you're in class you know people
people are like see writing raps give us
our last mention taking this and when it
on the ground you know i mean teachers
laughing at you dad laughing at you
everybody you know I mean like I got I
got a I got a daughter and like it's
rough when you got to tell your mother
and you're like yo don't worry I'm going
to be a rapper you know instead of like
and we grew up in chance you know she's
going for the city it's like everyone
around you understand everyone around us
all once the rapper so it's like oh god
what about to take the 101 of the around
I just recently found my confidence
right this year the first year that I
just like boost of confidence
um and it's because you know like this
idea of what cool is like burn into our
brain and I just don't think it's I just
I you know I don't think that I'm
starting to like open up so many more
thing to see how that many things are
just like up aside and being cool is a
total facade you know so I even even
celebrity wise like all those people I
thought were these awesome people you
need them in the salon charismatic so
lame so corny so uncool you know the
until saying like these are those people
that are like making us feel bad about
our bodies or our face or hair or
lifestyle or choices like up just
staring man I'm so over it so I you know
what man I say take all this Drive shrug
it off the cool fall off quicken it like
don't let them peak then let them peak
let's that's what I say let them pee
yeah who are you uh an underdog who
became a champion uh you know came from
the middle of nowhere and you know took
took about like two albums finding or
excuse me like seven mixtapes and two
albums to kind of find my voice and I
finally found my voice and um Here I am
on my third album with my first top ten
record I've ever had and it feels like
it's like the beginning again you know
me I'm likely inspired so uh you know
I'm 26 years old I don't give up and
dope and I know and I love and I love
pushing boundaries
liquidation confirmation fluid side of
the bed and I saw yellow is the puzzle
one of the things we like what project
[Applause]
it will be about classically because I
know it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
by
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Roderick asked
me to so there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
it down the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know what
a machine gun Kelly say that had the
biggest impact on you what Clips
resonates the most with you and why and
what immediate action are you going to
take in your life of your business after
watching this video leave it down the
comments below I'm super curious to find
them finally I want to give a quick
share this to Ariel XIV Ariel thank you
so much for picking up a cup of my book
your one word and flying to Toronto to
meet me and get it signed I really
appreciated the conversation I hope
you're enjoying the read thank you so
much for your support so thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon